Husband doesn't cook, but he does make tacos sometimes.
So he went to the store,
pick me up my favorite drinks,
and got started on making some steak and fish tacos.
Started by pickling some onions,
setting that aside
while he started chopping some cilantro to make a mango PICO.
I always get scared when I watch him chop stuff
because it looks very dangerous,
but so far he's always gotten it done.
He moved on to chopping up some tomatoes.
I'm so excited that summer's rolling around
and it's gonna be tomato season really soon.
I don't know what it is about a good tomato anyways.
He chopped them up,
added them to the bowl with the cilantro,
before moving on to peeling the mango.
After peeling it,
he cut it in slices and then dice them up as small as he could.
Decided to only add one mango because he didn't want it too sweet,
but he wanted that little burst of flavor.
So after that was all chopped up, he moved on to yellow onions.
If that rough chop as well
before combining it all with some lime juice,
heen and some other spices
before taste testing it and making sure that it was all good to go.
It's actually really, really good.
I had a little bit of it as well,
and he started prepping all of his toppings, which was some cheese,
lettuce, some Fresno chili,
some limes,
and he set it all out before Moving on to searing off his protein,
he got some New York strips and put them in the pan
to get an even sear on both sides
before basting them in butter and garlic.
Once those were done,
he set them out to reverse season
and rest while he got started on his fish.
Any white fish will work.
Whatever you have in the fridge,
and he seasoned it with some lemon,
lemon pepper, and salt.
This felt like the home stretch.
He warmed up the tortillas,
sliced his steak,
and then it was time to assemble the tacos.
These were so good.
Exactly what I wanted.